well there's another power mystical
power in game of thrones is the ability
of some characters to
become an animal by taking over their
mind
so let's check it out
skin walking shape-shifting you know
various
words for it in various legends and
various cultures and the navajo have um
have a version over here in new mexico
and of course
it existed in in europe in various forms
but again how to how to do this
realistically
i think the actual bodily change where
you know the the bones get longer and
the mass gets heavier and the whole body
rearranges well it's it's cool for
horror story and i've used it that but
it didn't seem to fit in game of thrones
so i thought well this skin changer
would be would be someone who actually
moves his consciousness into uh into
another thing not that his body actually
changed but he got his mind into an
eagle or or a wolf or had some bond with
them and can i tell you how brilliant
that is
because
what it took us a while to learn and to
embrace
but that
objects
that have physical existence that's one
thing
but the concept of information
doesn't have the same constraints of a
physical object
plus it's valued differently right so i
can give you two oranges and you have
two oranges but if i give you two
newspapers you don't have twice as much
information
no
it's the same information but duplicated
so
and we've also found that unless
one of them is to times and one of them
is the herald uh stuff like that then
you have completely different courage
um
so for you to transfer a consciousness
in a way you're transferring information
right that
that is completely plausible
relative to you're right bones growing
like the hulk becoming the hulk well
where did that extra mass come from
right you got you have issues
i mean in some ways
the ability to
transfer your memories transfer your
consciousness into something else is
the possibility of of uh you know
immortality if your memory survive
um
then you survive your your personality
whether it's in a robot body or a clone
body that we grow i mean science fiction
has done many different ways if you
assume of course that that's really you
that's what's been my issue with the
star trek transporter okay they
disintegrate your body correct and at
the end they
put together a new body from random
atoms that they get
and it has your memory and
it it thinks it's you but is it really
you
steve if you transfer your consciousness
is it still you
if you transfer your consciousnesses
it's still you
uh no no actually because
the you has changed from the time that
you did the transfer to the time it's
received right but if it's your
consciousness who else's consciousness
is it so it's a different consciousness
that's a different use so consciousness
technically folks they has to have three
things it has to be qualitative so it's
not measurable it's the concept of being
like something it's subjective so the
subject experiences it and it's unified
like i'm not thinking about the feeling
of my butt in this chair except that i
just said it so now i'm thinking about
feeling my butt in this chair all those
things have to come together combined
with my memories and my thought of
what's going forward you take my
consciousness out and put it into you
now i'm thinking of what your butt is
like in that chair i don't mean that in
any sort of untoward way
that's what i'm thinking about so
suddenly that's a new consciousness
that's what's so interesting about the
concept that he created in the story so
it's not just a consciousness that had
extra stuff that happened to it extra
life experience you're saying it's a
whole new consciousness yeah yeah so i'm
curious raja is there a in medieval
history is there any
uh
accommodation for the transference of
mind in religion for example sort of
especially in religion actually there
are mystical traditions according to
which a soul can be so connected to the
divine that it can get the qualities of
the divine
including looking into the future
looking into the past looking into the
present time but seeing other spaces
that the actual physical body is in
now telepathy telekinesis were not
categories that
medieval people operated on but they
rather talked of visions and prophecy
yes of course
it's it's full of references
okay so here's the question then steve
what's more likely to happen first
reanimated dead bodies as zombies or
transference of consciousness uh
honestly i think transference of
consciousness uh because as we get
better at mapping the way the brain
works we can then translate that into
the ones and zeros that we make things
like our smartphones possible and then
if anyone's watched black mirror in any
of these shows they've just watched game
of thrones we know that we can start to
then uh create a cookie of ourselves in
in ways that are both horrifying but
also kind of invigorating when you think
about it because then you can start to
think about horrifying and invigorating
in the same sentence i'm pretty sure
that's the motto of his lab where
they're doing these experiments
i didn't say we i just that time he
didn't say right right right yeah so i
actually think we'll be there i i think
we're in some ways we're we're there-ish
okay when you get there can you come
back on the show i would be honored